New Hampshire felt the burn and ran with
it senator Bernie Sanders gave this
democratic election its first clear
winner because of the hard work of so
many volunteers
[Applause]
and let me say tonight that this victory
here is the beginning of the end for
Donald Trump the self-proclaimed
Democratic Socialist commands a
dedicated passionate following they were
never in any doubt that he could win
this first crucial primary the energy in
this room the energy for this candidate
is enormous I've been working with
people like the last few weeks and
people are so excited they've come from
everywhere
see got that the others happen our
consistency and saying the same thing
for half a century Bernie Sanders the
man for the job but beyond this room
there's a dawning sense that sounders
has a very credible chance of becoming
the Democratic nominee
and it resonates with
but not everyone wants a revolution
especially in those
that's something that moderate Pete
Buddha judge is banking on he finished a
strong second a healthy follow-up to his
surprise Iowa win and I know that when
you talk this way you might get
dismissed as a naive newcomer but a
fresh outlook is what makes new
beginnings possible it is how we build a
new majority and election after election
has shown us that putting forward a new
perspective is how Democrats win the
White House and we will win the White
House
[Applause]
[Music]
but he could have some unexpected
competition in the moderate field
senator Amy Klobuchar finished just a
couple of points behind Budaj edge
exceeding all expectations
[Applause]
on the merits we have done it with ideas
and we have done it with hard work
because we are resilient
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Elizabeth Warren was the leading female
candidate a disappointing night leaves
her campaign with some urgent questions
but Joe Biden's campaign is surely in
the deepest danger
the former presumptive nominee came
fifth skipping his New Hampshire party
in a desperate bid to start winning
upcoming more diverse states these early
states are largely about faith after
months of uncertainty nervous Democrats
may be starting to feel more confident
about who they can trust to bring down
Donald Trump Amanda Walker Sky News New
Hampshire